peter
i you know i i've made the observation
several times this week these
quarterbacks i think they got together
and they came up with a schedule as to
which day of the week they would take
over the news cycle because every day
it's another quarterback or two and now
front and center it's russell wilson
again
yeah you know mike um if you look at the
absolute end game of this
i i'm probably a naive guy but i still
think
there will be peace in our time and
russell wilson will start the season as
the quarterback of the seahawks
but as we continue to go down this road
you continue to pick at this scab
and i just continue to think back to the
last time
i saw
video of russell wilson he was in
roger goodell's box at the super bowl
looking absolutely miserable miserable
and
i'm not laughing at his misery i'm
laughing because yeah he was miserable
and and you know i think part of that is
i'm at the super bowl i never play in it
anymore
and here comes 43 year old tom brady
parachuting into a brand new team
and i am watching tom brady are you
kidding me the man who torments my
dreams
and look i i just think this is about
russell wilson obviously
is totally unhappy with the situation in
seattle
if you're the seahawks
you can do one of two things right now
you can say well this is not how we do
things here
we don't allow
our players to tell us what to do
or you could say
you know if we trade russell wilson yeah
it'll be a lot more peaceful around here
but it'll also be six and ten
so in my opinion
i think the seahawks are probably going
to say listen
let's let this thing settle down let's
let it calm down
and then let's have
all families come to the table
okay
all families come to the table
and everybody just state what their
issues are
and let's get over them right now and
let's fix them right now don't just say
hey russell you go sit in a corner and
play it's obviously if that happens this
is just going to surface again
well and i think that we are back to
russell wilson as the a topic in the nfl
because
of past instances where russell wilson
has tried to exert some power and some
control over the situation in seattle
and they have told him go sit in a
corner and yesterday's events happened
not by accident the
story from the athletic
that that represented to me the first
time the seahawks spoke their mind on
this matter even though it was all done
through anonymous quotes given to the
various writers who name whose names
appear on this story
we started to see pushback against
russell we got the story of russell
wilson after seven turnovers in
back-to-back losses to the bills and the
rams going in to meet with the coaches
on a short week preparation
session for a thursday night game
against the cardinals with all sorts of
ideas peter for fixing the offense and
he was basically told we we've got this
and he stormed out of the room russell
wilson's storming out of the room that
doesn't mesh with the image that we've
had of russell wilson for the last nine
years but that gets put out there there
are other things in that article that
are unflattering about wilson
and and let's start with that peter
because my takeaway when i got to the
end of that article and it took some
work these long articles i feel like you
should get a t-shirt if you read all of
them but when i got to the end of it
i said you know what
if the seahawks don't
view russell wilson the way that russell
wilson views russell wilson why in the
hell don't they just throw the doors
open and let some other team that would
view him that way
give more
for wilson than what the seahawks
apparently think he's worth
i think the answer to that is
very very simple
they know that when they go to training
camp every year
they are going to be a playoff team with
russell wilson
facts history everything points to that
he's been on the team for nine years
he has started every game
since he was the 75th overall pick in
2012.
and he
you know has led the team to the
playoffs what seven of nine years
they've been to two super bowls
without russell wilson you head into
this murky world
of
who knows
no one has any idea what happens if they
let him go
and
all you can say no matter how unhappy
you are
with each other
the fact is
this is an organization
that held on to
uh marshawn lynch
year after year for at least two years
longer
than i think people inside the
organization really wanted to hold on to
him
because they knew that he was popular in
the locker room fans absolutely loved
him and you know he was still producing
some good things on the field so they
took all of his nonsense
if you hang on to marshawn lynch
for as miserable speaking of miserable
as he made people like john schneider
and pete carroll
are you telling me you're not gonna hold
on to somebody who's three times as
important
to the bottom line of this organization
i don't think so but if there's a team
out there that would make russell wilson
there patrick mahomes setting aside for
now the question of whether or not
wilson would thrive as the player
through whom the offense runs because he
did thrive that way initially in 2020
but then defenses caught up and they
didn't properly pivot to other things
and that's where i think it all kind of
fell apart in that meeting leading up to
the cardinals game but if you do have a
team that says this is mahomes this is
the guy we built the offense around it's
not a defense with a running game and an
explosive play action pass from time to
time this is the guy that we make the
centerpiece of our entire franchise
wouldn't that team
view that player
as being worth more in draft capital
players etc than the seahawks would i'm
just talking about what does it take to
tip the balance and to me if they don't
if they view him as a guy that okay he
thinks more of himself
than we think of him but he's good
enough to get us to the playoffs every
year so we're not letting him go i just
think if there's another team out there
that views him as another mahomes
they'll offer enough to get the seahawks
to say well maybe we'll find another guy
that'll get us to the playoffs every
year with all these draft picks and all
this other stuff we're getting for this
guy that we don't regard as a patrick
mahomes
did you hear the word you just said in
that sentence it was maybe
and so
the only way that if i'm the seahawks
the only way
that i would consider doing this
is if
it is one of the teams on his list that
has a quarterback who would trade you
that quarterback and that quarterback
you in your opinion
is 85 to 90 of russell wilson
that's the only way i would consider
doing it unless things get truly nuclear
okay who's on that list that you could
see that
derek carr maybe
dak prescott maybe
and so those are the things that's the
only way i'd consider this mike the
absolutely only way and again i'm saying
until i'm forced to standing on the edge
of the cliff and i have to make a choice
until that point
i want to fix this
and i want everybody to get in a room
and yell at each other for a day and a
half
and then let's see if it can be fixed
because mike
at the end of the day
i can tell you
that if the seahawks trade russell
wilson
and the next two years they go seven and
nine and six and ten
then they have failed mightily
and they have failed this franchise as
stewards of the franchise to keep things
right
well i don't disagree with that because
they do have a guy and this reminds me
of the texan situation in one very
specific way there are many many
differences between deshaun watson's
discontent in houston and russell
wilson's discontent in seattle i think
there are far more differences than
there are similarities but there's one
very important similarity
how did you let it get to this point
how when you have a franchise
quarterback how have you managed through
this falling of the dominoes for the
texans that happened fairly quickly for
the seahawks it's something that's been
simmering but it still got to the same
point where we have
peter something that
i can't really recall and i've been
covering this sport carefully for 20
years now this is a new phenomenon when
you have a franchise quarterback
shortlist franchise quarterback who
number one
is unhappy with his team and number two
even though they're doing it in
different ways is willing to make that
displeasure known to the point where
it's clear
they want out now it's more clear
deshaun watson wants out but i also
think it's clear russell wilson wants
out and we'll talk about why i think
that coming up but it that isn't that
odd that the seahawks for everything
they've done right the mere fact that
this problem exists represents a failure
obviously you know it just means that
uh that they either overlook some
signals or this became volcanic
very late in this particular year i have
a much bigger problem by the way with
the desean watson one mike because
you know
four months before you start hearing he
wants out or four and a half months
you know basically he makes over that
four-month period
28.1 million dollars
and he and he has a very happy tearful
emotional press conference
and you know so
i i'm i'm a little dubious about this
oh he's been treated so poorly in
houston i mean you know you seem pretty
darn happy four months before that
and if you have one
lying to you
yeah okay but but but you know i'm
dubious about watson let's just say
but when we talk about russell wilson
we'll we'll talk about it but when we
talk about russell wilson
the one thing that that sort of bothers
me
just about this is the long-term aspect
of it
this didn't boil up in the span of four
months this has been growing you can
just tell
and right now i think that's why i think
this has to be addressed and this does
this doesn't get addressed over zoom
this this gets addressed in a big room
with four or five people in it and
that's it you know socially distance and
all that but you have got to get
together and try to solve this before
the thing blows up in your face
and
the seahawks didn't come out of that
article yesterday from the athletic
unscathed one of the points that was
made is a point that's been ricocheting
around the nfl ever since russell wilson
went on dan patrick's show right after
the super bowl and said things that made
us all say holy crap what's going on in
seattle the idea that pete carroll
doesn't have anyone there
to tell him no that pete carroll is in
charge that pete carroll runs the show
there's not even an owner there to tell
him no jody allen is not involved with
that team you know urban meyer found out
a couple of weeks ago in jacksonville
it's not like ohio state it's not like
florida there is someone there who is a
multi-billionaire who can tell you no if
things get off the rails pete carroll
doesn't even have that and so this is
going to be his call i believe
is he going to relent is he going to
give in is he going to see the light and
if he doesn't i don't see this happening
i agree with you now now i still think
there's a shelf life
as i said yesterday the shelf life for
russell wilson and the seahawks is
closer to bread than bricks right now
this is something that is going to end i
think three years absolute max two years
is the more likely outer limit next year
unless they win a super bowl is going to
be the year when things happen and he
moves on and i think if the seahawks get
to the point where they realize it's
inevitable that that's the other side of
this coin peter
once you know it's inevitable
if if you come to that conclusion
because i think from russell wilson's
perspective it's inevitable and he's not
going to stop and he's going to keep
jostling and he's going to say all the
right things when it's time to show up
and work he's not going to hold out he's
not going to refuse to play for the
seahawks but he's going to keep jostling
and he believes it's inevitable he'll be
gone he's under contract three more
years
once the seahawks come to that
conclusion
why not
why not if there's a great offer sitting
on the table why not and they may think
you know what let's kick the can for a
year because then somebody will spend
the whole year plotting their best
possible offer and we'll get more next
year and we'll have more of a chance to
plan for this but i think once they know
it's inevitable that's when you have to
start coming up with your exit strategy
for russell wilson
why are you positive it can't be fixed
i i just think that any relationship
between franchise quarterback and team
that gets to this point is not going to
have some sort of lightning bolt five
families meet what because you've
consistently resisted and refused to do
whatever it is that he wants you to do
and he's gotten to the point where he's
crossed the rubicon
football coaches aren't wired to admit
that they were wrong they're not wired
to say i'll give in and i'll do it the
way you want it to be done sorry i've
been
resistant reluctant for the past five
years now we have seen guys like tom
coughlin undergo an organic personality
change when his job was riding on it in
2007 but i don't see pete carroll as
he's closing in on 70 rolling out of bed
one day and saying you know what
russell's been right all along the
offense is going to run through him and
we're going to throw the ball 45 times a
game and it's going to be the russell
wilson show plus whatever we can get out
of the other 21 guys around him i just
don't think pete carroll is going to
wake up one day and come to that
conclusion and and if if it takes
the proverbial gun to the head that
russell wilson is holding the seahawks
at this point to get him to do it that's
not the ideal way to do it
well i agree with what you're saying
mike uh but i also would ask this
question
and and i think we both know the answer
okay
so
pete carroll turned 70 years old this
year
and i guess
the
you know if if russell wilson is
dispatched somewhere let's just say
then what the organization has done
is they have chosen
a 70 year old coach
with who knows how much shelf life he
has left
they have chosen a 70 year old coach
over a 32 year old quarterback who says
that like brady he wants to play into
his 40s
the way that russell wilson takes care
of himself and conditions himself and
and all that
i would guess
that he has 10 years left of playing but
let's just say it's eight let's say it's
eight let's say his career right now is
at the halfway point all right so
and so you know he's played nine let's
just say he's got eight left all right
so
do you think it's smart to choose
a 70 year old coach over a 32 year old
quarterback who has led his team to the
playoffs virtually every year since he's
been in the nfl i mean
that is the big question and you know
what in seattle
there's no one to make that decision
except
the 70 year old coach
so
you know i i mean it's a real it's it's
kind of a rubik's cube because the only
person i think who can step in is jody
allen jody allen would barely know
russell wilson if she met him on us on
the sidewalk
you know she's not she doesn't have any
relationship with russell wilson so you
can't envision
jodie wilson who is as reclusive i hear
as her late brother
you know it's this is
if you love the seattle seahawks you've
got to be worried about where this story
is right now
well and there's a belief out there that
that the seahawks management right now
is the closest thing other than in green
bay to a corporate ownership situation
where vulcan the group that paul allen
put together is really managing the team
and jody allen is just the name on paper
which puts even more power in the hands
of pete carroll i'll tell you a story
about pete carroll it's been three four
years ago at the league meetings
we had robert kraft on the show and i
asked him how long he would envision
bill belichick staying with the team how
how deep into his own life cycle bill
belichick stays and robert kraft talked
about warren buffett and rupert murdoch
and other titans of industry who work
well into their 80s and he would like to
see bill belichick do that that same day
i posed the question to pete carroll and
he said why stop there so carol doesn't
seem like the kind of guy who's going to
see his football or other mortality
staring him in the face and if he's the
one making the call
yeah you know what he may be thinking
i'm going to be here 10 15 years i'm
going to be here longer than russell
wilson's career at least whether or not
that happens he's thinking that and
that's going to be a factor in how he
resolves this look something's gone
wrong and it's gone wrong over an
extended period of time this is not a
new sentiment i've been talking about it
for a while and it always drove seahawks
fans crazy
every time i'd hear something about
russell wilson's discontent one of the
first teams i hear about is the cowboys
people that drives people crazy too and
here we are
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports